hey kkk are you a fan of cultural
appropriation
of course i can't go down to the local
supermarket unless i'm dressed like a
mexican bandit or as i like to think
about it
your cousin in that case you're going to
love beer rebel noodles
they make award-winning delicious ramen
noodles with an irish twist
for bankruptcy and alcoholism no all
their noodles are homemade using
high quality ingredients in fact
respected food critic jay rayner
called them deserving of poetry what a
cook man up jay
their sauces noodles and broths are
created using skills
that were developed over years of
working in michelin-starred kitchens
they're dead easy to make the noodles
take one minute to cook
and the whole dish takes only 10 minutes
to put together
in the comfort of your own home i'm
hungry just explaining this to you
you're always hungry mate i mean that's
a fair point go to beerble.com that's
b-i-a-r-e-b-e-l-dot-com
and get a tasty flavor of the east in
your dinner time
i i have real concerns about how
simplistic
it's become now with a focus on white
privilege and it's very divisive
you know no one reacts well to that
really if they're honest
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for
you if you want honest conversations
with fascinating people
our terrific guest today is a lawyer
health care executive and diversity
leader from k abanbola welcome to
trigonometry hello thank you very much
this is
here yeah the welcome to the show it's
good to have you on the show
uh we'll tell everybody a little bit
about how how this happened and all of
that but before we do
just explain to people what is your
background who are you how do you happen
to be sitting in the sea right here
talking to us
yeah absolutely so i'm nigerian born
very very proud of that
i moved here for educational uh
reasons many many many years ago now i
am from a privileged nigerian background
and that's going to be very relevant
for our discussion later on uh my first
career is in law
i worked as a corporate lawyer uh for
over a decade in different law firms
i then moved into the global
pharmaceutical industry and worked there
at senior leadership level for another
10 years
but all along i was very very concerned
about the lack of diversity
in the profession itself that people
were being excluded
from entering the profession i just
thought given what we do as lawyers it's
very important that's representative
of the full population and i started
doing a lot of work around that
about 20 years ago and i've been doing
that ever since
and it's interesting that you mentioned
that because actually the reason that
you you you contacted us and you wanted
to come on the show and talk about it
you actually expressed some concerns to
us about the way the concept of
privilege is now being discussed and
i i don't want to put words in your
mouth but i got the sense that you felt
that
some of the terms and the language
around it was becoming quite divisive
and unhelpful
so what made you want to talk to us
about it
i wanted to have an objective platform
to discuss this and i was finding that
that wasn't widely available and i
couldn't understand why and
i realized that my message is probably
not as as popular or mainstream
as maybe the bigger media would be
interested in hearing about you know
the idea that it's not all about white
privilege
goes very much against the grain now and
there's such a focus on white privilege
that it completely excludes
other forms of privilege that could be
factored into why
some groups in society do better than
others i i have real concerns about how
simplistic
it's become now with a focus on white
privilege
and it's very divisive you know no one
reacts well to that
really if they're honest and that's why
i got in touch with you guys to see if
you'd be interested
in having conversation about it so so
let's just get into the conversation
uh what do you think of the idea why of
white privilege and the way it's being
used at the moment
i think it's overly simplistic um it's a
broad brush approach
that can be very very convenient if
you're trying to push
a certain type of agenda but ultimately
it's not going to lead to an inclusive
society
and white privilege is a very very
nuanced concept i mean i'll give you a
good example of
my own awakening around that you know
nigeria is part of the commonwealth
i was born in a post-colonial nigeria so
the hierarchy was
very very firmly set in terms of if you
saw someone white and still you know if
you still see someone white now you
assume they're an expatriate in nigeria
and there are afforded privileges and
lots of assumptions flow from that
behaviors and so on
so i came to this country with that sort
of frame of mind
albeit that i'm from a privileged
background myself
and i realized very quickly that not
everyone who
has white skin has socioeconomic
privilege which is of course what we all
assumed in nigeria
right and and the biggest wake-up call
for me was i started doing work with law
firms
around diversity and i remember speaking
at an event almost 10 years ago
and the senior partner of the firm stood
up welcomed everyone
i was doing a speech and in my mind i
was thinking
you are the problem you know you're a
white guy in your 50s
you're the reason why no one you know if
you're black if you're
uh you know lacking um financial you
know funds to get into the profession
it's your fault that people can't get in
if they're disabled you know all these
underrepresented groups were going
through my mind and
that was the dialogue i immediately
assumed and i thought don't act on it
you know talk to the guy first but i'd
be lying if i said that wasn't what i
was thinking
i spoke to him and we've become the best
of friends since then
he's great friends with my son who is
the same colour as me
and 18. this chap is now in his late 50s
still white you know that's not changed
but i made so many assumptions about him
he wasn't from a socio-economically
privileged background at all
i think he still is the first in his
family to go to university
he had slogged it out to reach that
position it wasn't easy for
him and actually was doing so much to
improve the lot of
others but i immediately assumed that he
was the enemy
and thank goodness i didn't act on that
my fear is that a lot of people do act
on that assumption
and it leads to so much misunderstanding
society
and that's what i'm trying to to stop
from happening
funky what do when we use the term white
privilege what do you mean by that
so what i think i think is meant
it means in some contexts is that
for historical reasons and we can talk
about you know the slave trade and how
that
set a hierarchy around the color of your
skin and
imperialism and colonialism but for
historical reasons
there was a clear pecking order based on
the color of your skin
and you know the the whiter you are the
more privileges you got you were treated
better and so on
now that's for very you know hardwired
historical reasons
and the media has picked up on that now
like the media just reinforces
uh that messaging so i think that's
what the understanding of white
privilege comes from is that very very
simplistic
view that on the face of it the
assumptions that are made about you
will vary hugely depending on the color
of your skin
walking around trying to get here today
you know
people would not assume would they that
i'm a lawyer i've done this i've done
that because i'm a black woman and it
wouldn't immediately
cross anyone's mind that i've done all
these things
so i get do you think that's true like
if you open your mouth i would
immediately assume
that you're well educated from a middle
class background probably are a lawyer
but that's because you're woke yeah i'm
the worst of them all
as you well know but do you see what i'm
saying like yeah
particularly in this country the class
thing is often due to your accent
and also the other thing just to pick up
and i want to open up the conversation
is
even that analysis seems a little bit
simplistic to me and here's why
i'm not sure that you get white
privilege if you're in china or in japan
i've been to japan you don't get any
white privilege uh or in maybe in the
middle east there's other places where
the majority aren't white
being white not necessarily an advantage
so i
i accept the idea of majority privilege
um and i think that's a more useful
concept if we want to talk about this
do you want i completely get what you're
saying and that's why i myself
am struggling to come up with a
definition of it because i
you know the reason i'm here today is
because i actually don't believe that
that's the case so i'm struggling myself
to
but what i would say is uh where someone
has made assumptions about me because
i'm black so
my first interview many years ago uh for
corporate solicitors role i walked in
suited and booted i'd spend a fortune on
my suit i looked the part
i walked up to reception and i said i'm
here for the job with and i named the
name of the corporate partner
and the receptionist said oh that sword
i thought he already had a secretary
so it could have been because i'm female
possibly
and i said i don't know about his
secretarial status you know i've got no
idea
i'm here for the junior solicitor's role
she was mortified embarrassed and so on
now
you could think you know what what made
her assume that maybe because i was
female
but when i actually interviewed in that
firm there were no other black
solicitors at that firm
the only black women at that firm were
secretaries
so in her experience she assumed i must
be a secretary now for me
you know i have nothing against
secretaries i was hugely supported by
secretaries and i was in law firms
many of them are still close friends now
but the assumption that i was somehow
less than in some way or i couldn't
possibly be a solicitor
and that sort of thing carried on
happening throughout my career
i've been assumed to be the trainee
solicitor when i was actually quite
senior now
you could say i look a bit younger than
i am and you know could explain it away
in so many ways but
it was assumed i was a paralegal when i
was almost at partnership level
and on and on and on so that's where i
can begin to see how
if i've been a white woman in that
scenario would the same assumptions have
been made
so i can see what aspects of white
privilege could apply there
but as you say i open my mouth and
people immediately realize that
my goodness me you know this is no
paralegal
tea lady whatever it might be this is
someone who's from a privileged
background
do you think that's again just exploring
the argument right because i
i wasn't there i don't know what
happened but
i i i remember trevor phillips who we've
had on the show recently who i have
tremendous respect for talking about
this on andrew mart's show many many
years ago and he was saying
well you know one of the ways that uh
structural races manifest itself is
when i walked into the broadcasting
house today to do this interview someone
asked me who i am here to collect
right now i can totally understand
why as the individual in that situation
that would be upsetting
right because you are being judged on
how you look absolutely you are
there's no question but equally the
person asking that question
that it could just be because of history
and because of
how recently the waves of migration have
come into this country
when i've been to broadcasting house
several times the truth is
most of the people who are from ethnic
minority backgrounds there are
security uh you know whatever
and that's that might be a product of
racism but it might just be a product of
history and so
you know to say i don't know i just feel
very i
i'm curious about that aspect of it
because it could be just people
responding to what they see they're
going well all of the black people i've
seen in here before
have been doing this kind of job so i
assume that and you know when i was a
translator i looked very young
people would make all sorts of
assumptions about my skill level
because i looked very young and i'm just
i'm just worried about how
i think sometimes there's a temptation
to weave a few different incidents
together and suddenly you get like
racism when
we may not have been do i completely get
it and i have to be honest and say
whilst my pride was wounded by these you
know
random instances that i've mentioned
there are few more along with them
levain
i could live with that with the
explanation you've just given
where it became a real issue for me was
when i was trying to enter the
profession
so my name is obviously not an english
name
and i've now been qualified for over 20
years so we're going back a long way now
but name discrimination is real when
you're applying for a job does
that support them and you know there's a
lot of data that shows and
i was i was genuinely shocked by that
because
up to that point you know privately
educated
aspirational parents i'd worked
incredibly hard
done really well academically i got into
a top law school
as far as i was concerned i'd done
everything that was expected of me
and i was really shocked when
i would get automatic rejections for
roles uh
friends of mine who were west indian
with angler-sized names or getting
interviews
some didn't have grades as strong as
mine so after a while i thought hang on
a second
something's not quite right here so
you can look at that and say if you have
a more anglicized name
you'll do better right you may or may
not actually be white
ironically but you'll at least get your
foot in the door
so that's not the element of where i can
see the white privilege argument
uh sort of aligning but if you're polish
you'll have problems right right it's
not really about being white this is the
thing and that's why i
genuinely struggle you know when you ask
me what's my understanding of white
privilege
i find it really difficult to actually
answer that question
because it's so nuanced that just using
it as a blanket
term is problematic you've got to look
at the context
and look at what the actual barriers are
in that scenario
do you know what i mean absolutely i
know absolutely what you mean so uh my
mother's
from venezuela he's never mentioned it
on the show before
but my mom wanted to call me francisco
jaime and my dad because it was in south
london in 1982 went
we're not calling that boy that name
because he was worried about racism yeah
therefore i was given an anglo-sized
name and that's why everyone now thinks
i'm a woman
but do you not think as well that
we use this term white privilege and it
it
stopped being an explanation of
something it stopped being a discussion
point
and it's now being used as a weapon
almost yeah and that's what i have a
problem with
i think we need to talk about privilege
take away the the white
aspect and attaching that to it and talk
about the different forms of privilege
you know
let's look at what privilege actually
means it's an unearned benefit
so i'm privileged because i happen to
have been born
into a niger the nigerian background
that i was born into
my parents believed in me had high hopes
for me had the financial means and on
and on and on
it would be remiss of me to say because
of white privilege that somehow
i was fundamentally disadvantaged i mean
it's it's
crazy for me to say that and i think
using white
privilege as this weapon as you as you
say
is so divisive you know it gets people's
backs up
if you're from a white working-class
background i mean you also actually
think hang on a second
what what privilege are you talking
about you know i do so much work with
around socioeconomic access to the legal
profession because
there's some real problems there you
know funding and
not being able to get into the right
schools and you know the profession is
still
very very rigid in terms of the
requirements to enter
so i'm very aware that you can't use
white privilege
in that that setting you know someone's
gone to a failing comprehensive and
they're white
how on earth can i say to that person
that they enjoy white privilege
they don't do you know what i mean so
it's it's it's become a weapon and it's
become
in my mind a very lazy way of trying to
circumvent
some more nuanced conversations that
need to be happening around this
and it's not inclusive you know it's not
going to get us to this society
where there's open access based on
talent and that's what
i'm all about if someone has that talent
that should be what gets them in to
whatever profession
and it shouldn't matter you know if
they're gay that you know whatever the
the underrepresented group is black
white whatever
are you talented do you have that raw
potential
to become a lawyer doctor you know a
techie computer scientist whatever it
might be that's all that should matter
very utopian i know but that's what i
believe anyway no i agree with you
uh we're sort of starting by analyzing
some of the stuff that other people are
doing and i want to get to the healthy
conversation
yeah but let's address another word
which i think and you know
i introduced you as a diversity leader
and i think diversity is another word
that is now being increasingly misused
diversity no longer means diversity
like uh it seems to taken on a new
meaning
uh and i think as a friend of mine was
tweeting about it the other day he
posted
a bunch of photographs of a diversity
board
and they're all black and you're going
well i'm not sure
this is diversity like i have no problem
with with a group of people who are all
black getting together and advancing
certain interests
but let's not pretend that this is
diversity right this is
just an advocacy group for one
particular which is fine there's nothing
wrong with that
but but it's not diversity anymore like
and we've started to misuse that
that word as well i think mike graham
when we had him on the show he made the
point about
uh the korean film parasite everyone
celebrated this diverse movie
winning the award he was all koreans
right do you think that's a word we're
starting to
misuse as well i think so and i have my
own
sort of definition i'm all about
redefining terms right
let's do that it starts with diversity
and it's actually
developed from vernon myers who's the
inclusion strategy
um vice president of inclusion strategy
at netflix so
she talks she uses this dance analogy
and i'll walk you through the steps
because it's really really powerful
so it starts with diversity which is
being invited to the party
inclusion's being asked to dance so i
thought actually once you've been asked
to dance
you want to be able to dance as if no
one's watching you right at a party so
that for me is stage three which is
belonging and then we're working towards
equity
which is where you're actually on the
party planning team you can decide who
gets invited
the mix of guests and so on the problem
with just focusing on diversity
is that it's actually very superficial
so to your point
it could be all about the visual
representation without factoring some of
the other aspects that are important as
well
we're actually working towards diversity
of thought you know to be on that party
planning team using my final stage
uh analogy we want as many diverse
groups around that table as possible so
you're not inviting the same types of
people to the party for example
that you're not you know having the same
types of parties i mean it's a silly
example to use but
it actually really really gets the point
across about how you might want an
organization to feel
once you've got the equity part sorted
out
interviews you know so in being invited
to the party who decides who gets
invited
and making sure that's a diverse
representation of society
so you're right diversity in itself is
hugely problematic as a focus
equity is quite a quote-unquote
problematic word for a lot of people
because
uh you know it gets used by different
people in different ways
and to some people what that means is a
quality of outcome right it's not about
your talent which is what you were
talking about before it's about
you know black and white people in all
circumstances should have the same
outcomes
and it seems again very blanket
sometimes what do you mean when you use
that word
it's actually the equity of access
to to come in and be able to make
decisions
that that's what really drives and
influences change in organizations so
it's not enough to be invited in the
door and that's why we see some
organizations where
at the lower end of the organization it
is very diverse
across many many different
underrepresented groups and then the
higher up you go
arguably the less diverse it becomes now
that is why
equity the way i define it is important
you know equity means something
different if you're a corporate lawyer i
mean it means you're getting shares in
the company
so i'm really really aware of what
you're saying um but
if you don't have the quality of access
the equity of access in the first place
how are you going to have the outcomes
at the end you do need that pipeline
of of the diverse talent coming in the
door in the first place
isn't that just a time thing though to a
large extent just like
you know we've got all the diversity
initiatives now they're
seeming to be working broadly speaking
right so 20 years 30 years from now
the senior positions are all going to be
mixed and you know filled by different
people anyway isn't isn't
that basically it it does take time and
that's what i say to all the you know
clients i work with
now i say you need to be patient more
than anything else
this is a 5 10 15 20 year plan
it starts with engaging young students
in schools
you know in years nine and ten in the
local community disadvantaged schools
getting them in for shadow work
experience and that's how you build up
the pipeline
um and some clients want the quick fix
you know arguably so they'll be looking
straight away at the board appointments
and that's where it can be a problem
because you know people can think you're
a diversity higher and you know all this
sort of very very insulting
even if you're worthy of the position
often there's real resistance that
approach
i prefer the long slow steady approach
where
you know you're supporting young
children very very early on
and then they then join the firm later
on and they work their way through that
way
and i think that's a that's probably the
best way of doing it because we talk
about diversity
you know it's all very superficial
because if you look at
you know the legal profession how many
of them come from a council estate
from middlesbrough how many of them come
from very very poor background
i would hazard a guess that even you
know the people who are asian or
black or african whatever background
they come from are all
probably quite wealthy and very
privileged yeah they really are i mean
it's something like
almost 50 percent um i think of partners
so that you know
sitting on the sort of leadership team
if you like
uh are from privately educated
backgrounds when only seven percent
of the children in this country have had
a private education
so clearly you know i mean that's a
nonsense right and
you know i did a research piece just on
that you know
just on the social mobility challenges
because i could sense that that was
happening like what's going on you know
um how many more people from a private
background doing that
in this firm and you're absolutely right
there's a real bias
in favor of those who are privately
educated
even the universities that people
graduate from in the league profession
it's very elitist russell group you know
the top 24
and for some firms oxbridge you know
they really they go for the oxbridge
graduates
uh and and that's what they prioritize
so it's an issue
you know it's a real issue and do you
not sometimes feel as well that
like we talked about it like you know my
partner she is
uh she's puerto rican well american
puerto rican heritage and she said that
she went to
uh columbia university and she said that
because there was this diversity higher
that she
had to overcome this feeling that she
was only there
because you know she was a token in her
way of putting it
do you not sometimes feel that when we
do these diversity drives
that sometimes it has this unexpected
consequence as well
whereby the people who then get there a
lot of the vast majority of time
off their own backs aren't taken as
seriously sometimes that can happen but
there's a way that
when i'm talking to my clients that you
know the messaging around
why you're doing what you're doing is
really really important for instance so
you know it has to align with the
strategy of the organization for example
uh it has to be all about you know
maximizing potential of the business the
organization
uh improving the benefit of the service
to the consumer the customer
you know the product that you're
developing these are the sorts of things
that actually get
gets people on board and away from this
tokenistic idea because the problem is
if you don't have
interventions is the way i call it where
you are setting targets
and saying we've got to make sure on
this short list
we have a 50 50 short list change just
it just won't happen
and you know you look at the shortlist
and you think why is it that we're not
getting
the more diverse you start digging
deeper and seeing what are the barriers
earlier on
to those individuals not actually
getting shortlisted
one of my clients admitted recently that
there was real hiring advice
they'd you know large um i shouldn't say
well it's an investment bank i wouldn't
say anymore
don't say it we're gonna need your
services if you said
someone could defend it but they reached
out to me you know because they realized
that
they'd interviewed over 20 uh black
candidates out of a large cohort
and not a single one of them progressed
beyond first interview
and all of them were from top
universities had the experience
so you know this recruitment manager
said there must be so i mean i can't
believe
that not single one of those candidates
progressed
so i'm working with them around bias and
you know the hiring managers
what is it that's making you think that
you know selecting out
who on paper are outstanding candidates
do you think part of it is as well we
just feel more comfortable with people
who
have the same political opinions as us
you know that look the same at us
because we're inherently tribal by
nature
affinity bias is real yeah it really is
and that crosses
racial lines you know i'm i'm a divorced
you know single mom
uh if i hear someone's interviewing and
they're also a divorce single mum
i will be in favor of them getting the
job bigger
and because of that i've always made
sure i've had others in my team
who don't have that bias so that i don't
have a whole team of single moms i mean
you know
and that's because i'm very aware with
of my own lived experience
what they might be going through and i
want to help them right because they are
like me
and they could be white black blue green
you know it wouldn't matter
but because we have that affinity so
that is a real thing
and it applies you know going to the
same school same university
same law school so affinity bias is
is really what we're trying to overcome
with some of these more nuanced
decisions within organizations
yeah absolutely and you think the best
way to do that is by just having going
right
then when you do the hiring process it
has to be 50 50. would you
are you in favor of just having sort of
blind cvs
yeah i'm a huge believer i've seen the
results
you know having blind cvs at the
beginning you unblind the process
obviously at some point because you have
to meet the candidate
but the final panel needs to be a mixed
panel
people from outside that team very
junior members of other teams
those often lead to the best and fairest
decisions
everyone on the panel has equal
weighting as well so i've seen this work
very well in the civil service actually
they do this quite a lot and a lot of
public sector organizations
do that the final decision is driven by
true diversity of thought
and you have you know intergenerational
you know they try and factor in
as many different aspects and and ways
of thinking
uh as possible and you can get a much
fairer decision that way
than if you didn't do that that's really
interesting they found an american
american football i don't know if you're
familiar with this they i can't remember
the name of the
rooney rule the rooney rule is that oh
yeah what they did is basically they
introduced a policy where
they had to have a black applicant for
the coaching position
as part of the shortlist and they just
interviewed them they didn't have to
hire them
and what they found was that was a way
to overcome whatever structural
barriers still existed and when you got
the person in well you judge them on the
merits and if they were good you'd hire
them
[Music]
and i'm really enjoying this
conversation because i think it is
inevitably true that all human beings
have some sort of bias
and i think one of the things that has
started to happen
over the last five years has been
the the pushing of this divisive stuff
that we talked about
earlier is now pushed people into a
corner
and now no one wants to admit there's
any bias of any kind in society and
you'll see
in the comments under this interview you
know but actually we are all biased to
some
extent now you know i'm not biased
against black people but i am in favor
of
let's say people who are from the same
economic background or the same people
who understand the same jokes or get the
same references or
or did comedy or whatever it might be do
you know so we all have some sort of
bias
and now we don't want to admit it
anymore because the moment you admit any
sort of bias
you know oh you only hire single moms
which you didn't say but that's how
people hear it
right and now suddenly you're a bigot
you know and
i just worry about that so much because
we have to be able to have an honest
conversation
about these issues and we can't anymore
because the moment you admit
any flaw any prejudice of any kind
you know you're in trouble you're in
real trouble i i just
i think that's a big problem it is and i
i guess for me what really disarms
people when they meet me is that i do
own ups my bias
i mean i've said this very publicly
about the single mum thing there are
many other examples by the way
um and suddenly it's okay to admit to it
because what i what i teach everyone is
that you can overcome your biases
by saying if this person wasn't a single
mum would i still hire them for the job
it's a simple question to ask right but
just turn it on its head and flip it
around
you know i had a colleague where i used
to work previously who she came up this
concept called flip it to test it which
is exactly what i've just shared with
you now
and it's a really simple way of keeping
your biases in check
because we are lazy as human beings you
know this
affinity bias thing your brain goes into
overdrive there's too much
decision making information and you just
want shortcuts to make a decision if
someone's had the same
lived experience as you looks like you
etc etc
you have affinity with them because it's
easier for you to process that
it's harder to try and align yourself
with someone
with whom you feel there's no
commonality but the reality is we have
so much more in common
than than divides us and and this is
where i'm trying to get everyone to
around these issues but do not think as
well
what you know it sounds like you're
doing great work but in many ways you it
sounds like you're swimming against the
tide
because more and more for our society
with you know the rise of identity
politics says
well you know you're a black woman and
this means this and you're a white man
and that means this and you
it just fills up we're sort of moving
away from each other more and more day
by day doesn't it
in some circles i would agree with you
definitely
but with with the work i do in
corporates
i'm seeing incredible things happening
there that i never
ever anticipated could happen you know
i'm hearing
you know back from clients feedback that
i never thought
they'd have that light bulb moment in
the way that they have
but you need to be willing to be
vulnerable so i am very very open
about what i've you know where i've got
it wrong and i give silly examples of
things i've said
which really again disarms those who
think that i've always got it right
like you know i'm still learning like
everyone else right
um so i see real hope with with many of
the organizations and there's some large
global clients i work with
who are doing incredible work around
this and
the way i sort of see it is that
there'll be a different burning
platform for different people there'll
be a different reason why
they want to get this right and i just
try and tap into what that reason could
be
it could be all about the profit for
some i really don't care if that's the
reason what what they're focused on
if it means that the actual work
environment will improve
for those who have the talent to be
working there and that's what it's
really all about for me
it's a really really important thing to
do because i think where the resentment
comes in is when people feel they
haven't been given the opportunities
that's where people get angry and upset
and quite rightly so if people think
that they don't have a chance of doing
something
then they become resentful of course and
you know you could have done everything
right i mean you could have worked
really really hard
overcome so many hurdles to get those
grades
you know being raised in the council of
the state you know this isn't unusual
some of the kids i mentor
come from these really tough backgrounds
and the thought that they would then be
denied access
because of their accent you know where
they went to school
automatically ruled out because of their
name whatever it might be
quite literally breaks my heart i find
it just crushing
to see that happen but slowly that's
changing you know with some of the blind
cv and other techniques that
i mentioned earlier those things are
really changing things but it takes time
and how do you feel about uh the fact
that
you know with some of the changes that
have happened i do think
we are increasingly encouraged to see
rejection of our application let's say
through that lens to some extent so
you know you've talked in the past about
having to
apply 150 times for jobs and whatever
i i remember when i was at uni i
remember applying for
50 internships i was a lot lazier than
you right only 50.
not getting a single positive response
now at the time it never would have
occurred to me
that that was because of my name i kind
of thought it's because i'm lazy and i
haven't
worked as hard as i should have done do
you know what i mean but i do think if i
was
20 now i think it'd be quite tempting to
think about things that way
i'm just really not so sure that that's
a healthy way to think about these
things i think
even when you are potentially being
discriminated against there's only
really one answer on an individual level
which is to work hard and to
to get your foot through the door you
know somehow yeah and that's the thing
you know
i did have to make 150 phone calls
you're absolutely right and i shouldn't
have had to do that because
you know i i i ticked all the cri you
know all the academic criteria all the
things that
were priority for law firms so it was
genuinely a surprise and when you see
others
getting the interviews and you're not
and you know you just realize hang on a
second
i've got better grades i went to a
better university or whatever but
i think also it's a fact of life that
we're in an increasingly competitive
world
you are going to face more rejection for
some of these opportunities
and there'll be times when it's got
nothing to do with your race gender
you know sexual orientation it's just
that maybe there was another candidate
who was better than you
you know uh and sometimes you just have
to keep trying
and hope that you have support around
you to to keep you hanging in there
which i did have thank goodness
but many people don't even have that and
and that's why
it's so difficult for some if you didn't
have the support if you didn't have the
family structure
you know i would have given up frankly
if i hadn't had my dad saying
you've got to keep up this if i hadn't
had my husband at the time saying
there's no option for you not to keep
trying you've just got to do it
there are many people who don't have
that and again i was very privileged to
have that support
you know yes francis always says you've
got to be like the ugly guy in a
nightclub just
come coming up to everyone
[Laughter]
just be respectful that's all just
approach respectfully
but actually you know we just had mercy
morocco on the show yeah uh i don't know
if
you watched that interview and you know
you talk about the parent
situation you know you talk about
privilege all you want the number one
privilege is to have two parents who
love you yeah
very important it's just and without
that all the data basically shows if you
don't have that
your life is that much harder it's so
it's so key i mean you know even though
my ex and i are divorced
you know we co-parent we have the same
values high aspirations for our son
support him
we're on his case i mean that you know
when he wants to give up piano if you
yes there's absolutely no way that was
going to happen he's glad he carried on
right that is the most middle-class
thing i've heard in an interview ever
giving up piano i thought you're going
to say he was having trouble at school
no no the poor boy just gave up piano
bam
there were other things you know he was
lacking focus in other ways and you know
the discipline of the piano exams was
what he was actually resisting at the
time
uh so even that's more nuanced than what
i said earlier but
um but you know as a black boy in this
country the statistics say one thing
but he's got two parents a wider family
you know goes to great school
so he's been given every advantage to
maximize his potential
but the family structure is key it is so
so
important and anyone who glosses over
that just
you know is being really simplistic
actually it matters of course it does
it matters a huge amount you see it
right the way through education and
particularly boys as well they need that
stabilizing influence of a father
because once they get to a certain age
mum can't control them as well yeah and
it needs dad to go in and go
you're you're starting to take the mick
now you know it really does and in
situations where
you know dad is absent for whatever
reason you know a really good mentor can
plug that gap
you know i was involved in david lammy's
review of the criminal justice system
and he asked me to
look at role modeling funnily enough you
know of all things uh so i you know i
walked into a workshop with
10x offenders i mean you know it's one
of the most uh
interesting episodes of my life shall we
say but it was fantastic talking to
these young men because
what had helped them turn the corner
once they'd left prison
was they'd you know aligned with
organizations that ran
you know focused mentorship programs
that plugged the gap if you like because
the father was absent
and mom was having to do two or three
jobs to keep the you know
fair play to the mothers i mean that's a
terrible situation to be in
and that's what turned things around for
them francis so
you know the structure and support is so
so so important and if you have that
i think you can really really achieve
great things
francis do you like biscuits stupid
question
if you like biscuits as much as him you
have to try
zingy berry bakery they're a small
family-run bakery that make
award-winning sweet cookies and savory
crackers
francis will explain how many awards
they want weren't you francis
the sumptuous cookies are made with
whole grain oats and real butter while
their savory crackers are made with
whole grain oats
and are both wheat and dairy free
they've got a brilliant offer
all you have to do is enter our code
which is of course triggered
on your first order and you'll not only
get 10 off
they'll give you free delivery as well
that's 10 off and free delivery on your
first order with our code which is
triggered
go to zingerberrybakery.co.uk the link
is in the description
it's zingerberrybakery.co.uk and get
your biscuits today
i think i'm eating too many biscuits
never heard him say that before
wow
and we use the word racism a lot and we
bandy
it around look the reality is
there's always going to be people with
unpleasant opinions unpleasant thoughts
how big a problem in the corporate
environment do you think racism is
you're never going to be able to
eradicate it completely are you
no you're not but there's a spectrum of
sounds like you're defending yourself
especially you just can't get rid of it
i think we should just you know
you know live and let live you're never
going to get rid of of racism
but what you can do is come up with
practices and processes if you like that
drive the behaviors
that will combat uh these you know
racist
you know race-based decision-making if
you like and that's what i'm seeing
happening in the corporate world you
know around the name discrimination
point
you know having more people getting the
interview in the first place
with a non-anglicized name has led to a
lot of change
within some organizations but you know
we also have classism
there are other forms of isms that
actually could end up trumping
race-based decision-making in some
places
what we're trying to do what i'm trying
to do is move away from the isms
and let's focus on the raw talent right
well this is where i find this really
i think a healthy approach where you go
look all this stuff
exists to to some extent i think it's a
lot less than it would have been 20
years
ago and this is something else i want to
bring up but generally speaking
let's get the best people for the job
let's get the best people for the job
and then
whatever color shape whatever they are
it's kind of irrelevant
you know that's how we always think and
trigonometry when we need to take on
somebody to do a certain job we don't
care what
what color or whatever they are we just
care can they do the job
and yeah i understand there's going to
be some you know unconscious stuff going
on there
plus we help deprive communities which
is why we've got a scouter
[Laughter]
our producer but uh but
i was going to ask you about the the
time of this because
i think so much of this conversation is
people responding to their adolescent
experience or their experience 20 years
ago
even the situation you talked about as a
as a woman with an african name applying
for jobs
i'm not sure that is as true now as it
would be then
certainly i don't know about law but in
comedy like if you wanted to start
stand-up comedy
you'd be on live at the apollo about
three weeks from now
because people would be like it's great
you have a you know a charismatic
young black woman coming through let's
give her a hand up
and you'd be you know promoted probably
ahead of
your skill level even sometimes because
of that's how it is and i think
we are now in a position where things
have started to change and it's
important to kind of like
not just keep your your pedal to the
metal in in these drives do you
does that make sense i agree i mean
certainly over my 20-year career there's
been huge improvement
huge improvement that now that's not to
play down in any way
the very real issues that still persist
but i'd be lying if i said the world 20
years ago when i was entering profession
is the same now it isn't and i can look
at law firms
and see that broad range of talent
that's coming through
and the data backs that up it's not
happening as quickly
as we might like but it is happening and
you're driving societal change in a
sense
of course it's going to take time it
can't happen overnight people
need to build up their experience before
they're promoted you can't
track certain processes so that's where
i have
i see huge encouragement can be drawn
from that where i compare you know it's
important to look back and be really
objective actually
about the way things stood you know my
son is going to have
a much better outcome in today's world
despite all the
you know divisiveness and all the things
that going on
he will now know confidently
that he will do well and that he's less
likely to have some of the challenges
that he could have faced 20 years ago
and and that's just a fact and those who
say that's not the case i honestly i
think they're deluding themselves and
trying to hold on
to an old narrative but things are still
very very tough for some and we can't
move away from that either
you know that's a fact as well and the
thing that people always point out is
the ceos i imagine their head lawyers is
probably very very it's still very
white male et cetera et cetera mostly
about height mate
okay you'd be crushing it yeah did you
know this
i think 93 percent of top 14 500 ceos
are over six yeah
one i think yeah yeah i'm just saying
what about me
right what about me but how how do
do you think changing that is gonna be
is it's just a question of time or do
you think that
more needs to be put in place to change
the fact that people at the top
still tend to be publicly school
educated
white and male 1 even that is changing
over time i can think of at least five
managing partners in law firms
who are black i couldn't i mean 20 years
ago
i would never thought that was possible
you know
and not all from you know
socioeconomically privileged backgrounds
either
you know one of them the ladies is far
from it you know very very deprived
background again i won't name her but
she'll know exactly who she is
if she watches this so it takes time
right it takes time before people become
partners
you know to be promoted to partner you
need to have good clients and be billing
a certain amount and
we don't want to shortchange that in any
way and patience
is so important in all of this you know
we just need to
keep at it and slowly but surely that
change will come
but we must avoid divisive language in
that process
yeah and do you think it would be
helpful to celebrate how far we've come
to some extent
do you think that's a good thing or do
you think that's you know not doing
justice to the people who are still
struggling
i think there's a careful balance to be
struck there which is why the report you
know tony seals report
backfired spectacularly i mean there
were lots of issues around how it was
delivered
you know certain race correspondents
weren't invited to have a look at the
report beforehand
should have been and there's a lot of
you know really bad mismanagement in
terms of the release of the report
messaging that came out which did not
help at all what the report was trying
to do
in some sections was celebrating the
progress that has been made
but unfortunately it came across and i i
read
the whole thing twice just to be sure it
came across
as playing down some of the real
challenges that still persist
like what what did you think it was play
that was being played down by the report
so it was oversimplifying the family
structure
uh piece to the point where so i'm a
single mother right so according to this
report
my son should i mean it was very simple
if the father's absent from the home
that that then means all these outcomes
but that's not always
statistically speaking across the
population but you know
so i immediately got my back up because
i know lots of divorce months and you
know
whose kids are doing well and the way
that it separated out
different ethnic groups as well was
helpful up to a point
but again was actually quite divisive as
well so the point that was made about
black boys that if you're
black african and west african
specifically your outcomes are better
you know what are the solutions to that
though is what really should be
should have been fleshed out if the
father is absent well what can we do to
to support the mom who's struck you know
so reminding the mom that the father is
absent which a lot of
you know people i know read it's just
very emotive
stuff that doesn't move things forward
and
a lot of people are justifiably very
upset
by the way things like the the slave
trade was sort of summarized as the
caribbean experience
that i mean that is a really insulting
thing to say to someone who's def
descended from slaves and you just don't
you know
which okay maybe i'm not understanding
it and
possibly some people watching sure what
do you mean
it's an insulting experience to say i
think the distinction if i i read the
report as well obviously
was that if you're a black african like
you are first generation
i imagine your ancestors did not
experience slavery that would be the
assumption
whereas the reason potentially and this
is my opinion
that caribbeans in the uk do less well
is that they were the descendants of
slaves in many
cases and also they are they came to
this country not in
you know 2000 or or 1995 or whatever
but in like 1960 when there was overt
racism and discrimination
uh i think that was the point of the
report so what was insulting just to
clarify
so the reference to the caribbean
experience was actually to the
experience of slavery
it wasn't the caribbean experience here
in the uk okay and that
really got a lot of my friends from that
part of the world i don't know
why i just don't follow the way it was
perceived was that they'll play you know
they
very neatly summarize what was a
horrific period of history
using those two words and some people
felt like this wasn't a cruise i mean
caribbean experience makes it sound like
you went on a cruise ship and had fun in
the sun and
i didn't see it that way but i had to
accept
that of course i wouldn't because i
that's not my you know my ancestors
didn't
have that direct experience so i had to
accept
that because my friends from caribbean
had very very different way of looking
at it
it was a far it was a very very
inflammatory
use of language for which some of the
commissioners you know
admitted that actually this is what they
meant you know they publish a
clarification document
and they apologize for the use of that
phrase
so whilst i didn't read it that way and
this is the point that we must remember
the way the message lands for me you you
know there'll be someone somewhere who
their lived experience is a trigger for
them and you've got to actually accept
that
and try and find a more collaborative
inclusive way
of trying to drive things through and
it's a real shame about that report
you know if i'd had the chance to help
to write it even
i would hope that i'd phrase things
slightly differently
and had a bit more balance about just
how tough things are
for people now still in the uk from
certain communities
it's interesting in particular you were
saying how tough things are for certain
communities could you
expand upon that point a little bit more
well the socioeconomic point
is is the biggest leveler that we we
face you know if you are
born into a socially deprived background
irrespective of your race
you are going to find it challenging it
becomes a vicious circle i mean you used
to be a teacher didn't you
you know you'd have seen this with the
kids you know it's very hard
to overcome getting the top grades when
you don't have the sport at home you
don't
have a quiet place to work at home these
are things that some of the young people
i meant or tell me
that you know my son's never had that
problem right he has a quiet place to
work and
we've had to push him on occasion to
actually make good use of that
but you know he has that support around
him and it becomes
very very difficult if you don't get the
grades then you can't get into the top
universities where you know that's the
preferred university of choice for many
many employers and on and on and on
now if you are born into a socially
deprived background
and you're also a visible minority
that's a double disadvantage if you have
an african name
it's a lot to overcome it's a lot to
overcome if you think about
the many many many different steps that
you need to go through
to get those good grades to get the
qualifications
to actually stand in good stead for
these really good jobs
and there's a huge section of our
society that is struggling with that and
i think
that's what the report was sort of
trying to get across that
there are pockets where that's not the
case
but actually they tend not to be those
who are
socially deprived in some you know i
wish they'd looked a bit more into the
socioeconomic aspects as well
you know it became too simple the
nuances that were drawn were far too
simple for me
but it's a tough job to do right that's
what i was going to say in this
political climate like someone is always
going to find a phrase that triggers
them and and
i'm not saying it's it's not reasonable
i don't know
but it's it's a very difficult job to
prepare a report like that
where and i come back to the question i
we started this bit of the conversation
with which is
how do we celebrate the progress we've
made without
you know dismissing the fact that some
people still have a hard time with it
a good tweet i think for me the way i do
it is through role modelling
you know i'm i do all sorts of things to
get the positive stories out there you
know i'm doing a podcast series at the
moment i'm
interviewing a really wide range of
leaders different sections is it out
already
it's art already what's it called it's
called the power of privilege and
allyship
and i'm interviewing many many different
types of leaders some actually very
junior but are still leading
in their own way different backgrounds
different races
different socio socioeconomic
backgrounds my son features in a few
of the episodes because he's had such
positive
impact if you want to call it that from
some of these individuals like the
gentleman i immediately assumed
was the problem when i went to his law
firm you know he's very good friends
with my son and
they talk in one of the episodes about
how that relationship
how they've learned from each other and
you'd never
i mean if you look at the two of them
they couldn't look more different
and yet they've supported and learned
from each other and
that's the magic that can happen when we
open our minds to it
so it's important that we try and learn
from each other as well
around some of these lived experiences
and open things up a bit more
can i pick up another language thing
allyship
well that's i wasn't going to say that
but actually
i mean we can get into that if you want
uh but a lot of these words they
they're like the trigger words for the
left the trigger words for the right
there's trigger words for everybody
right
so lived experience is a personal
trigger for me
and i tell you why because i'm like why
do you need to put live that's just your
experience
do you know what i mean like what why do
you use that phrase
i suppose lived is that you've really
really felt it it's almost like
you need that validation that i lived
through this and that was my experience
um but yeah i mean i get your point you
know if you say my experience was this
i suppose the fear is that someone might
say well was that your perception more
than your experience
it might get watered down but the thing
is all lived experience is perception
all of our experiences
go through our filters and we don't
really know what happened okay well you
brought it up yourself
let's talk about allyship how can
francis and i be great allies
so again this is another you know word
that gets people's backs up they don't
really understand what's meant by it
i talk about becoming friends with
people understanding where they're
coming from
people who aren't like you and that you
happen to work with because i i do this
in the workplace right
it really is as simple as that and i
give examples of
very simple things you can do to stand
up for that person
calling it out you know i've been i'm a
straight woman
i've been in rooms where terrible jokes
were being made about homosexuality and
that you know
we've apologized he was off camera
okay what are you doing here but you
know i will call that out
and i have done and i've said that you
shouldn't be that's completely
unacceptable
and that's what being an ally means is
that you call out that behavior
you know you stand up for something you
know i've done often in meetings
where i notice that someone's not had
their say i'll make sure the person
leading that meeting so you know
draws out that person's opinion i'll say
you name the person
or do you have any thoughts about you
know that's what allyship is is about
where i've enjoyed allyship uh in trying
to you know the cause of getting more
diversity inclusion
in the legal profession corporate world
is where i've i've partnered with
you know white men because in some
circles that partnership is really
important right where
you know opening doors for meetings to
talk about these
uh cultural issues that can happen in
the workplace has
only been possible because i've got a
friend you know who's also an ally so
you know he's put action behind it who
knows the
other senior partner at that firm it
gives me i suppose a bit of credibility
if you want to call it that
that we're on the same page and we're
driving the conversation together
it also means that there's less
suspicion of what my motives might be
right
if i've actually allied with somebody
who looks
more like them it's a joint effort then
so that's where allyship
is is really really key and that's why
so much change is happening in some
companies you know people
sign up to things they can be doing you
know actual day-to-day stuff
they can be doing to drive this change
and it has a real ripple effect
across the whole organization well well
i've got more questions mate
i'm sure you have i'm getting if you
don't have anything i just wanted to
ask a couple of more things that's cool
with you look i've loved this
conversation and it's great and i wish
i wish to god that when i'm on i don't
know good morning britain or whatever
it was you sitting there and we were
having this conversation as opposed to
i'm not going to name them but you know
the usual people uh i just wish that was
the conversation i wish this was the
conversation we had in the mainstream
because i think you're making good
points
i really do and i may or may not agree
on everything but
at least we're having a conversation
right um
i just think it's so important but one
thing that's become quite contentious in
recent times is
unconscious bias training yes oh hello
i've never believed in it i've i've
never seen
you know it's i'm so glad
that if there's an area where i'm glad
there's been a backlash
i'm really glad unconscious bias
training has been seen
for what it is you know it's not as
simple as that
i see this as starting a conversation i
really i've seen magic happen from that
start a conversation doing reverse
mentoring you know in one firm it was a
50 something year old senior partner
who's male and a black
socio-economically you know deprived
trainee solicitor female
i i partnered them you know paired them
up as and the magic that happened
you know she had misconceptions about
him and vice versa
together they came up with all sorts of
solutions to drive
uh you know things forward no amount of
unconscious vice training was going to
achieve that
you know we need to sit down and start a
conversation about these
really difficult um experiences i won't
use the word lived
but um by having conversations and
actively listening which a lot of us
don't do we're
waiting to interrupt all the time you
know we're just waiting to get our point
across
if you actively listen to that other
person and listen to what they've been
through
you can find more common ground if
they're willing to do the same for you
i've seen incredible things happen so
simple and yet
we don't do it we don't do it enough so
why do we persist with this unconscious
bias training then
if it doesn't work as you yeah as you've
alluded to
i guess it was sometimes seen as a quick
fix right you bring someone in
you pay them this amount of money they
do it they run a session you can tick it
off
my approach takes longer i mean it does
right you have to feel the quick fix
mentality you've talked about
you know but the reality is for for
sustained change
you need to invest the time but it's so
worth it
you know it really is and it is
again it comes down to that quick change
but isn't it also as well because it's
about perceptions and perceptions of
reality and
look how tolerant we are we've had 32
diversity trainings
this month alone yeah yeah and for a lot
of organizations
who are you know looking at targets in
that way you know the way they set out
their targets
is you've done this in this quarter
my approach is harder to sort of
quantify in that way right
so i had to come up with different ways
of of gauging success
you know hence reverse mentoring you
know how many work experience schemes
have you offered to
years nine and ten in the local schools
you know these
are the sorts of you know metrics i hate
that word but you know that's what we're
using in corporate circles
and that way you can measure in the same
way companies like to have
things to measure right they like to
have figures and track things and so on
but i think we've been measuring the
wrong things quite often and i'm trying
to change that
that mindset all party thank you
well it's been an absolutely brilliant
interview thank you very much for coming
on the show
uh the last question we always have is
what's the one thing that we're not
talking about but we really should be
so i'm really worried about the mental
health
uh implications of lockdown i
see a lot of really worrying trends
around that especially with young people
they've been robbed of so much
opportunity because of these you know
school closures
and it applies to a lot of young people
you know many of whom
are coming up to voting age or will be
voting at the next election
and it's really really sad that the
government doesn't seem to have
become alive to that in any way and
they're not really
planning how they're going to deal with
that it's a real problem and we really
should be talking about that more
it's massive it's something we've talked
as much as the youtube guards allow us
to uh about on the show quite a bit and
i think
you're absolutely right it's a massive
concern and it's massively
under it's not included in all the
polling about everyone who thinks
lockdown is great it's not including any
of that
but there's a lot of people who've
killed themselves there's a lot of
people who've really suffered
and we get emails every day from people
who are saying like
you know your your shows or whatever is
the only thing that's keeping me in any
way saying
and with all due respect to us i just
don't think that's our job and
you know that's a big worry it's a big
worry you're absolutely right
no it's very concerning on that happy
note uh
where can people go and uh check out
your podcast and anything else
uh to find you online etc so i've got a
website
um which is from carebola.com i'm on
linkedin
uh as dr funker benvola mbe i've got a
twitter
account which is at champ one diversity
um and i'm also on instagram with my
business name the austin bronte
consultancy
so there's no excuse for not getting in
touch
well perfect thank you so much for
coming on and thank you for watching we
will see you
very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one or catch a raw
show tuesday
thursday friday or saturday 7 p.m oh
they always go out at 7 p.m
uk time we didn't say that you could
have just said uk time no
we're just gonna have a domestic
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below